Emerson is with us in Pennsylvania hi
Emerson how are you hi Dave I am so much
better than I deserve thank you how are
you better than I deserve
how can I help I am a 26 year old single
mother with a three-year-old I work
full-time and I am going to school
part-time I make less than thirty to
thirty thousand dollars a year and I
have been stuck in baby step three for
about two years just because I keep
using what's what's left of even just my
number one emergent like my baby
emergency fund just to get through the
year I end up using my tax return or
what little I get of my tax return to to
supplement my baby put my on my
emergency fund and then that ends up
getting used up throughout the year
because I can't make it I can't even pay
for a whole lot of food with just my
monthly income and so I'm feeling stuck
and I do I know that my problem is my
income I would really I am in school to
try to get a degree I don't have a
degree but I'm trying to get one in
order to be able to be marketable and
try to get a better job in order to you
know in order to bring my income up such
um scratchin an clawin kiddo good job
yeah so what are you studying I'm
studying to be a parent be a paralegal
but I have a ten-year plan to get my law
degree and when will you finish the
paralegal paralegal I will graduate from
my for my associates and the spring of
2017 and right now I'm paying for it
with grams okay all right
and so basically we're saying a year and
a half right I know yeah yeah and then
and then things are going to change
because paralegals make more than 30
grand right and so that's going to be
very helpful so um and and where do you
think the leak is in your budget what's
the biggest thing that you think's
taking your budget down probably gas
money I have to drive about half an hour
to drop my daughter off at daycare
because my work shift which is the only
shift that I mean
able to get right now as second shift in
in order to find a daycare that is open
that late I have to drive into the city
and then I also work in a different town
out of the city
that I have to drive to about 45 minutes
from the city to get to work and so I'm
studying about 300 hours a month on gas
which is you know it's eating up what
what I could have spent on food and so I
think last month for September I do you
see every dollar budget tool and for
last month in September I could only
warm out 85 dollars for food okay
well let's stop that idea here's the
thing food is first right it's not last
it's not wormed out you start with food
because you have to eat before you can
do anything right and struggle with that
I've struggled with that my entire life
I'm not an anorexic but I'm very close
to it I don't really eat a whole lot
yeah but you have a baby to raise and
and here's what's happened here's what
this says okay the biggest tool that you
have to clean this mess up is you and
you have to eat right so in other words
to feed the program we have to feed you
right so you need to look at it that way
that this is a proper value system food
is first lights and water is second how
much is your rent so that's another
thing is 695 out of my 1650 that I have
for every month
yeah and so your your rents killing you
mm-hmm it's not your food and it's not
your gas your rents killing you I know
that's still a cheap rent that's not
it's not like you're not in a lot of
money but as a percentage of your income
um that that's what's there do you have
any family in the area um I do but not
that I'm able to ask a whole lot of help
from my mother lives about an hour away
and she's she as much as she wants to
help and she tries to help it's not it's
not fiscally responsible for me to ask
her for help because he's not and
they're not in the greatest financial
situation either that's fair that's fair
okay um and and what are you doing
what's the job you know I'm right now I
work for Hospital registration I
actually work for like a clinic I do
basically that when
you go into a clinic if you know you
hand your photo ID in your insurance
card to a person that's me
gotcha okay yeah and you're making
thirty thousand just under actually yeah
well let's do this uh yeah if you can
adjust your rent that's fine it would be
very helpful because I think that's
what's knocking your knees out from
under you I think that's what's kicking
your feet out so but if you can't then
let's pretend this happens let's pretend
that you just keep putting the emergency
fund in place but then something breaks
or something and it keeps coming back
down and between now and the time you
graduate you don't make any progress but
you stay but you'd also don't go into
that right you just kind of you just
kind of hang on by your fingernails
right right mm-hmm if you can hang on to
eighteen months then that's where your
light at the end of the tunnel is was
because your incomes going to change
dramatically and for that matter your
life's going to change dramatically
thank you how $300 gas bills going to go
down because you're going to move to an
area that's very close to your job and
the daycare is going to be near your job
and that's going to just you know the
time you have is going to come back much
less your money right and so so yeah so
would it be worth it for me to move
closer
either closer to my daughter's daycare
or I mean to try and to try and do that
I mean because I might be able to get a
cheaper rent in the city but the
environments not that great there's
shootings probably every week yeah we
don't want to get you in this place it's
unsafe don't put your baby in this place
is unsafe but I probably would shop and
just you know try to take a little bit
of time and start looking you might
stumble into what I always like to look
for is that thing that nobody knows
about that you find out maybe through
your church or something and it's the
garage apartment out back of some rich
old lady's house and she just kind of
takes you in and you know lets you you
know rent that garage apartment real
cheap I like that kind of a thing that's
the type of weird you know you're not
looking for a straight-up apartment from
a straight-up landlord I just I'd like
to find some kind of an unusual thing
that would cut your rent down while you
finish this degree okay cuz we could cut
it down just a little bit it would
change everything
listen Emerson you put
put food at the top of your list it's
your number-one priority you don't do
anything until you buy food for yourself
and that baby do you hear me yes sir
okay I don't want to hear from you
otherwise on anything else I'll help you
with anything I can anything I can you
call me back if you're scared or you're
struggling but you make sure you're
eating okay yes sir thank you
all right you call in again
you